it's et's late-night roundup your quick
catch up on all the most buzz worthy TV
scoop after dark
[Music]
after more than a dozen years at FoxNews
I have decided to pursue a new challenge
just hours after megyn kelly announced
her departure from Fox News to start a
new journey at NBC the journalist opened
up about her decision on Tuesdays the
Kelly file and revealed she'll be
leaving the cable news network at the
end of the week I am very grateful to
NBC for this opportunity and I am deeply
thankful to Fox News for the wonderful
twelve years I have had here I have
grown up here and been given every
chance a young reporter could ever ask
for
thank you for watching with love over on
The Late Show with Stephen Colbert Oprah
Winfrey was a guest after years of
hearing her do her signature welcome
Nicole Kidman she revealed the celebrity
who originally inspired it John Travolta
was on my show many years ago and I said
you coming up next John Travolta and it
just sounded so good please welcome our
favorite
[Applause]
meanwhile James Corden started The Late
Late Show off on a reflective note
paying tribute to the late George
Michael who died from heart failure on
Christmas Day the iconic singer was the
first star who agreed to ride in a car
with Corden in 2011 as part of a bit for
charity the segment eventually evolved
into carpool karaoke when we started the
show here we were trying to get people
to do carpool karaoke and not many
artists wanted to do it and we would
send them this clip of me and George and
we sent it to Mariah Carey and she was
the first person to say yes and her
words were if it's good enough for
George then it's good enough for me I'll
do it